hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to west of loathing now
I just got back from pax and I did not
mean for this series to go so long
between episodes and that's why I'm here
to tell you right now that I'm gonna be
playing this to completion
probably a video every day probably more
than a video every day and probably a
whole bunch of other stuff but we got to
go to the Baker boys I okay you spot a
small makeshift signpost stuck into the
ground a few yards away from the road
stop to check it out it says free mate
and indeed there's a small pile of meat
lying in front of you you're so
distracted from rolling your eyes at
this obvious trap you almost missed the
goblins sneaking up behind you he's
wearing an old Buffalo skull as a helmet
which you have to admit looks really
metal I gotta hand it to you you nearly
got me a good job huh foolish human is
falling into my clever trap now you are
giving me valuables where I beating you
up
you know it's maybe the first time I've
been mugged by a goblin usually you guys
are more or less peaceable I am smart
like human why making things myself when
robbing easier smart like human is very
accurate description of that idea yeah
Gary talked to this guy
Oh convinced the gavel is something
they're talking too fast plainly
belligerent and Gary starts to look
exasperated what a jerk being hoping
other cop links around you're not jerks
like that Goblin how'd you get them
leave threatening to report them to
goblin elders who nobody wanting bat
they're real tough hombres eh they're so
sassy
they're so sassy and DeeDee dude they
are you know bakery seems like a strange
place for a band to die doubt but I
probably should have stopped being
surprised by now bakery where people
make bread do you guys that bread sure
yeah making a bread of cactus cactus
bread I'd have thought the cactus would
be too watery dude grind into flour
no no not whole cactus just prick lers
alright thank you for that thank you
very much just gonna go on my way and
smack into these bad boys they're
forests that one give me that loco weed
what does local we do you're just crazy
about this stuff no I I mean percussive
not about using combat to get more
exploits okay hello hi I am here now
dumb I mean perusing through your stuff
hello these teenagers seem dispirited
and are trying to drown their sorrows in
big mugs of water maybe they
misunderstand the idiom hey you boys
wouldn't know about some bread that went
missing would you not I told you we'd
get in trouble Billie shut up Jerry we'd
just blab about everything now do you do
the mayor just wants his bread back and
over in the trouble you'll be in will be
minimal he ain't that simple mister we
sold that bread for me to start up the
bakery why cuz we wanted to make
something out of her lives everyone in
bread would it's just bombs Plus like
everyone needs bread right so we figured
we'd make it big
ok well no problem we take the mayor the
bread you've made and called even well
yeah no problem except for the fact that
we don't have a dang thing about making
bread it turns out what we ended up with
weird lumps well that ain't true Billy
the last love we tried was almost right
yeah sure that one was merely edible for
we're practically out of ingredients
maybe I can help
I've got an idea he'll I don't know wait
what is this what is mr. County gonna do
here I don't have time I'm smart enough
to cook a dangle Oh for bread just give
me whatever ingredients you have left
then we won't learn how to bake
ourselves Oh fine all right then fine
I'll think of something else I got an
idea
I can teach you boys what to look for
there's plenty of cactuses and wild
grains you could use this sounds hard
and boring but you'll have a lot of
different options for ingredients and
what customers want is variety that's a
good point
I don't mind forage and if you just want
to do all the bacon Billy all right then
schools in session all right you teach
Jerry how to find the wild ingredients
they need while Billy works on figuring
out a proper recipe after a couple tries
I manage to produce a decent amount of
loaf of bread and bake enough to cover
what they stole from the mayor hey four
loaves of bread
oh thanks for helping us maybe you
should go set up a shop down and watch
him we'll call it town where to whoa I
need to go back to bread would a mare Oh
heard a crackle fork lining I'll fight
it whatever it is mmm
hey you wanna get shot all your teeth
man that thing dies fast now I'm too
powerful for my own good I'm out here
then when he walk over a deal so
essentially ah yeast bandits taking care
of Baker boys got him done
library book half of it well that's a
real bagel biter oh well everybody
mostly skip the words and just look at
the pictures anyway I don't remember
what the voices are I'm mostly just the
bottom half of the pictures so that's
all I had these the captions are their
logging permit not meant to bring back
the soup I need five bowls soup
missing mail not yet cemetery well I am
not anywhere near where I need to be but
I'm gonna go take care of it was soup
talking about soup stock load see a
campfire campfire owners offer you a cup
of coffee and suggest a round or two of
poker while it boils you can tell from
the look in his eyes that he was
planning to cheat so were you so it's
probably fine deal me in your opponent
gets really angry when his four aces all
spades are beaten by your five kings all
hearts it grabs the comfy bottom stops
away leaving with you you with an
unusually thick deck of cards what I'm
not gonna use that as an item alright
fine men yuck yuck yuck all right got
that tuna cactus
what are you savory talese meat oh hello
I hope there's another spittoon in here
these lockers have been pretty picked
over from the looks of them all right
well that's not so bad a lodestone ring
what is that 20% of meat kings oh that's
awesome
what do I have right now oh just pistol
attack I'll get meat gains I don't I
don't know how that makes my gains more
meaty but okay oh there's toolbox on
this bench but it's locked
welded to the bench okay got a hammer
and a monkey wrench okay I can hammer
things and I can wrench things now I
don't know how good that does me
I'll just grab that with my hand hmm
using a bread you scoop some soup I've
got a bowl up I don't know how that
worked exactly but I got a bowl of soup
all right I got a bowls ooh
that is what it is and that is woody
whoo what do you got over here for me
hello a knapsack oh that's where I could
have gotten to cult this mask oh that
would have been nice good thing I got
enough Moxie to convince him all I
wasn't an idiot
all right elevator you see three
different sized bolts on the side of the
elevator which are all very use loose
there's a sign that says 3,200 pounds
pressure is required and some sort of
gains we currently return number three
for a11 706 867 all right doing great
love it love it love it love it love it
whoop died goofed it hard loosen all the
bolts now this is just another math one
all righty then you roll good number 30
to 90 okay Wow there's a son of a [ __ ]
there's gonna be a son of a [ __ ] I can
tell by the bitchest miss of the son
that it is yeah yep okay and try that
one
Hey oh it's working now I just guessed
my way to that one okay well I go okay
hello what's down here let me cartwheel
into there excuse me where are you gonna
take me now should I be worried Oh more
soup I just realized why is there a soup
mine
okay whoa municipal Croaker's cast up in
kuru kuru schoo i don't have enough key
stones to be able to do this well at
least I know there's something in here
so there's something do all the sail
vibrate otech I'm not gonna see hello
there are hundreds of snakes lounging
around in this pool of hot soup wraps up
the super the snakes
I guess it's almost shooting a knee what
that didn't do diddily but oh well
you're gonna get carried Wow okay that
was weird how about some of this action
bang I got stewed snake I got stewed
snake well he's my meat games are up
what is this there's a lot of heat but
you can take it
great I don't know what that means but
I'm pretty sure if I were to drink the
soup from the snakes I would have been
able to resist that it's gonna blast
these guys one more than hey yeah wait
why are you wait tougher a muscular
snake not muscular enough okay bye
alright see you then see you guys yeah
see you around yeah alright oh not that
not that not that man okay I'm out of
here I guess I'm done right I got the
soup got the soup was the abandoned well
dude there's a lot of stuff here that I
need let's go to Fort memoriam there's
got to be some down there that I need to
do right probably yes alright what do
you got for me
hello here nice hats not many people
would walk around in a cow hat in this
day and age not to imply their wherever
in fashion or anything
hi I'm mum Fleur yeah I'm Melvin you the
cemetery caretaker no I think Jeff said
something about having a day job it
hasn't been that day for like two weeks
though alright
what's with the hat we're doing
historical reenactments you're playing a
tabletop wargame okay sure but a
historical one anyway we only switch to
this after we quit doing real
reenactments why'd you quit it's too
much exercise well so somebody kept
refusing to lie down when he got killed
okay
rules are pretty complex I don't think
the others will want to stop
I already know it my brother used to do
it okay alright then the hell is this
play their little game okay oh we got
the jump on him this time what the hell
am I Hey all right he'll miss I got hell
bolt hell missile this revolting human
will be utterly destroyed he'll he'll
he'll he'll raise all right okay got an
infant steer over here you want to be
hell raised these guys medic
McBrine will directly attack whatever's
in front of them well I mean that's
handy I guess how about I utterly
destroy this guy oh that's Andy Oh No Oh
No please don't be so he's got 15
m-might don't hit me Oh God oh no I'm
gonna die
Oh Frick shut up shut up probably should
have probably done that better hang on I
can do this no should be you should be
fine this should be fine everything yeah
body getting wrecked okay gonna play
another one
hell yeah do all these oh [ __ ] I don't
know what you all this was you oh well
there are ding damn it damn it
Oh ding damn Domon okay well that didn't
go nearly as good as I thought it was
gonna go well
maybe that's gonna kill nah so close
that's so close okay we can we can get
him this time he's gotta heal myself oh
there's a gonna last but if I smack this
guy then we swim swim yeah and then we
smack this revolting human if we warn
easy bzz bzz bzz okay now there's one
more we seem to have reached an impasse
maybe I should have buffed myself hey
hey guys how's it going just wanna not
kill me
that's an option oh okay fine man okay
ah oh he can't hit me can't if you can't
hit me what can you do and nothing hey
this actually works out pretty nicely
and I just got to build up ap until they
die right look miss me this is easy flam
okay got it
okay nailed that one okay you prevailed
in the early service that's right wow
you're really good at this game
getting it was the only way to keep my
little brother from lording it over me
all the time
I feel like we should give you some kind
of prize and I've got some leftover guns
from when I was gluing the figurines
together you want them sure I got a
bunch really small guns great why what
good does that do me play another one I
already won them all well I don't want
to do that okay
hi you the cemetery caretaker whoo yeah
that's me did one of the other guys tell
you I try to keep it hush because people
assume your weirdo if you were gonna
graveyard I'm asking here to tell you to
get back to work because skeletons are
wandering about all over the place
causing trouble for the neighbors who
are nuts all right well look I'm on a
real winning streak here I'll go back
once it's over okay
looks like I broke your winning streak
also I'm in a Hornswoggle yeah you want
to be hornswoggled I broke your winning
streak all fair yeah dang it I just did
GG hey guys I gotta get back to work
I'll catch you next week ooh puppies up
if you want some candy
ooh I love sugared pork balls my
favorite increases your meat drop by a
bonus by 20% for the rest of the day oh
yeah those are awesome massive pile of
candy wrappers and empty snack bags
sounds good to me
just returned beeline for the spittoon
all right
the liquid in the spittoon is bright
yellow I feel like that's all that needs
to be said about that
look closer I'll never understand all
right well you crouch down next to the
spittoon from the nauseatingly sweet
stance coming off it it appears that
these nerves haven't been using it as a
makeshift urinal as you may have
suspected but rather they're using
bright yellow lemon lime flavor soda
flavored chewing tobacco unless unless
well another possibility is that they
have been using they're all extremely
diabetic which now I think about it is a
real possibility in fact it is probable
that both these things are true search
it really you're gonna put your hand in
the Nerds piss and/or spit bucket just
gonna dive right in there huh just gonna
split sprats around in that sticky
yellow broth of spit and be with no
restraint whatsoever I sure AM with a
fanfare of sad bones and a choir of
angels retching the sword Rises out of
the spittoon held aloft by a wet
bedraggled and miserable-looking
splashing your clothes with yellow slime
and officially declaring you mum Fleur
thumper dink king of the fifth
congratulations the sword clatters on
the floor as the hand drops it withdraws
into the sky there's a replica of King
Arthur's sword you know it's a replica
because there's no way history would
have allowed the original to be this
comprehensively covered in tobacco spit
long live the king Oh perfect Oh
wonderful go away st. beef is you're not
wanted anymore I got blessed caliber
Oh smells very bad alright I got Kurt's
fit pants oh wait is that the pants that
I need for the oh I know that's the
pants that I need for the dance this
shelf is stuffed full of rule books
about a weird game study them okay I got
an intermediate next max another
vampiric yodel skill mid tier next max
textbook teaching you how to replenish
your blood supply by stealing blood for
the living keeping enough blood inside
you is important to necromancer's and
civilians alike if I want that I don't
know if they want that at all all right
what are you doing talk to him the game
no I mean I love games that's why I hang
out with these guys but I've gotten
bored of these strategy war games I want
something different like what well I
like playing the guitar so I was kind of
thinking some guitar game where you
pretend you're in a band and you have to
hit the right chords that sounds hard if
you don't already know how to play the
guitar yeah I thought I'm making a real
simplified version of a guitar but then
that wouldn't make it much fun for me I
have an idea said about pretending to
play in a band why don't you actually
join up and play guitar for real I know
a place that's looking for talent put my
guitar skills to actual use it's not a
bad idea okay cool it's a jewel saloon
in dirt water tell him I saying you
takes a punch ahead all right now
Godspeed guitar man and now it's back to
the lonely drones or whatever the whole
instrument that is okay so we got to go
somewhere else but I bet now that I have
this mask I wonder what would happen if
I go back to the mad dismal mind
rectangular all roughly three feet wide
by six feet long by six feet deep so
it's either a grave or the future side
of a half of half an inground hot tub
jump in and what do you see oh the stuff
you find and it makes you lean more
towards the grave Theory grave dirt
skeleton bone teeth old engagement ring
okay thank you
thank you very much okay I'm gonna put
on my my Cultus mask no one suspects a
thing
hello alright goodbye then okay farewell
why did why can't I talk to you guys
okey-dokey then alright just ignoring
your compat rias here I see alright dear
Jeff I've already talked to these guys
haven't I
Oh Oh some fruit oh I gotta know I wish
I was a bean slinger Oh Oh had been
contained some sort of ancient machinery
that prevents psychic wave from passing
through it okay all right ooh must not
be enough oh I need more scraps oh I
didn't know that I was just wasting
scraps like that I'm very dumb I
shouldn't have been doing man should not
have been doing that excuse me while I
roll along my way let's go back to the
petting cemetery because I'm pretty sure
I need to Oh see what seems to be an
oasis in the boiling heat of this region
and spur Templar towards it as you near
it you discovered that you've been
fooled I wasn't an oasis at all but a
naval towering black stone cow monolith
he could make that mistake I'll fight
you I'll fight you well I won't fight
you anymore because you're dead all
right
excuse me all that's exorbitant okay
well anyway all right here's your
goddamn meat okay all right okay I'm
going in now all right hello oh it's now
Zen oh that's an owl take a picture of
it
Tsubaki got that all done right cool
it's a hawk skeleton Hawks resent being
mistaken for Falcons and will shoot you
if you do it too many times
okay Boone of the hawk sweet Boone let's
go back to Brad wood we got some more
stuff done and out of the way oh you bet
I want to trade you have a walk wander
and Sally do you have a lock I need a
lock I remember I need a lock
yeah you do I'll buy that okay so I need
to get rid of this just sell it you got
it
that hmm well I don't think I even want
the next mix so I'm gonna just probably
sell that that's good enough for now
that's good enough for now thanks Sally
you're always so helpful where was it
going bread wood that's right bread okay
oh god okay all right step bang your dad
okay thank you
hey mare we got some more stuff free
does this got him right here
cemetery yeah he's good too you're ok
cemetery man's already back underway now
about that alum er lumber all right well
you've helped me out quite a bit so I
reckon I can set you up with what you
need for that bridge
oh thanks mayor glances are the list of
problems posted on the wall and paces
around nervously goddamnit haven't I
gotten you your problems already what
else do I need missing male stalled
logging permit bad lumber deal given
lumber to the railroad company for like
no meat at all and that's bad
ah that's hilarious that's funny hey
buddy I did it I've got wood or bread I
mean same thing right hey buddy how's it
going hey boss good news we got that
lumber shipment in from bread wood and
we're ready to go
you got the Brit built already yep most
of the passengers were so bored they
chipped in to help
Wow nice now we just have to lay the
track to the rest of the way into Frisco
and our work is done both mine and yours
see you there boss Frisco where are we
going Frisco mmm Frisco What's in Frisco
I don't know if I wanna know what's in
Frisco ooh with the spooky combination
of hissing chattering and clanking an
ancient skeleton rises out of the sand
in front of you he's wearing dented and
rusted antique armor in a long handlebar
mustache must be an ancient Explorer or
some would-be Conqueror hopefully the
former because he doesn't seem to have
been much good at the ladder how does
your mustache stay on yes do you use
glue yes but I could have Hornswoggle in
five I'll fight you where are you bang
tough compadre well Gary's about to get
bone around yep there goes Gary bangin
ah me too strong old Spanish sabatons
nice wait the Spanish have heard of this
style of heavy Buddhists Avedon's
because they weigh more on Sundays I get
it
the Sabbath that's funny that's funny
all right we made it
Oh Gary what's up whoa it's going a
place a good place well we're a custard
standing Jesus should be used to this by
now
last custard stand that's that's
freaking hilarious that's frigging
hilarious Gary okay what's going on Smee
this fancy-pants calls and self the
Emperor and he won't let us build our
tracks up to the station can you see if
we can talk some sense into him about it
let me just go away
well I who the heck are you I am Emperor
Norton I'm in charge of this city you
can't build a train right here without
my permission
an emperor wears the crown then as it
happens I lost my damn crown full thing
didn't fit right anyway but without it I
can't issue any official permits I mean
no rail for you unless of course here to
give me a new crown properly fitting one
when the ground sorry what the heck just
happened well I guess that just tears
Joanie so not only do you not get a
permit but osteo he reaches into his
bargain Graham's a hand full of powder
which he throws in your face your eyes
burn ha have a taste of my famous
antivirus sucker your vision goes all
weird and you pass out when you come to
Norton is gone and so is drink excuse
you with the Train go that lunatic stole
it he drove it off somewhere into the
desert
Norton's got off the rails he's points
to a set of deep struts off to the side
of the railroad tracks you walk over to
investigate but you can't see it because
of the weird hexagon thing your eyes are
doing you should probably get that
checked out boss that Norton fella said
something about antivirus maybe
[Music]